Flatliners you have an amazing cast here
and we had diego luna on the show last
night who's amazing yeah and I
understand that you guys it's a great
cast you guys got together and you
bonded you got kind of like a cottage
together yeah whereabouts uh like in
north of Toronto and and in Ontario and
really it was on Nina
Nina's like the cool brat who's also in
the film right and she like organized
the whole thing and yeah it was real fun
and so like what kind of stuff did you
do to bond because I know did you guys
do acting exercises a bond you just hung
out together we did acting exercises we
went to bed at 9:00 p.m. we cooked
really healthy food you know that sounds
awful man you had healthy food no Nina
that's great mean I got all this stuff
to do slip and slide and there was like
all kinds of games no cool
yeah so you played you did some aside I
think he brought footage did you not
bring footage um I didn't bring it but
someone this is footage of you and Nina
Dobrev doing a slip and slide uh yeah so
enjoy
no one pitches these jokes thank you I'm
just curious I want to see this take a
look
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's how you bonded it actors
you